do you know what happens if you do not
respect the people
you get this story right here from the
independent lady gaga
dog napping fbi investigating political
motives
singers dog walker was shot and our two
french bulldogs were stolen they're
essentially saying check this out the
fbi is reportedly investigating
if there were political motives behind
the dog napping of lady gaga's bulldogs
after she sang at president joe biden's
inauguration last month
the pop superstar is offering half a
million dollars for the turn over french
bulldogs koji and gustav
who were stolen at gunpoint at a gun
point a gun shot
but luke you see a lot of people might
say what political motives you mentioned
something earlier
about this yeah i remember seeing some
kind of form of entertainment where this
was a plot line of going against the
bourgeoisie
and stealing the rich people's dogs as
form of like a cultural warfare i don't
remember exactly what i couldn't
pinpoint it when we were talking before
the show that's why i tend to bring it
up now
uh but but you know i i think there
might be a bigger political motive
potentially here i think it also
might be motivated by crime that has
been spiking in many big cities that is
going to go
dramatically up as of course our
economic woes continue
well they're saying the fbi thinks there
may be a political motive right
but i wonder in los angeles is that maga
country
i don't i do not believe it is huh so
could it be
some fringe leftist saying eat the rich
these people i think these people knew
who the dogs belonged i mean you got to
assume that they did right like the
other thing too is they didn't just take
the dogs they shot the guy who had the
dogs and then they took the dogs so you
got to assume i mean my hunch is it's
either
it's either for ransom or yeah like
think about where she was i'm saying i'm
saying this my initial assumption is
this is crazy for the fbi to insinuate
that's nuts okay it was probably some
guys who were like yo it's lady gaga's
dog shoot that guy take his dogs
but if the fbi has reason to believe it
was politically motivated i don't see it
as being right-wing
first of all oh definitely not
right-wingers going around shooting
people and stealing dogs does not make
sense to me
no it would have to be like if there's
anyone who's going to do that and i
think it fits the reason we all jumped
onto it earlier is
it it fits the the class war narrative i
think the democratic party of
if it's anything it's probably something
from like i don't know a communist
revolution that happened in china or in
russia where that's what they did to the
wealthy and
like as a form of punishment they took
the items that they had
that conveyed some sort of class status
right yeah it's no different than
stealing someone's range rover today and
so it's
like that's that to me if there is any
political intonation it has to be that
yeah i'd be curious that who in the fbi
is saying that they were kind of
investigating this i'd be really curious
what they were thinking the motivation
was because they're you're right there's
no chance that this is maga country
because this is
la that ain't magner country it's even
less so than it was in chicago when
jesse smilet was dealing with it
oh poor man um but uh these dogs are
very expensive and i feel like everybody
knows that and i think that this is
probably just
crime honestly and i guess this has been
kind of increasing so i don't know
i mean they're like two thousand dollars
i mean yeah
is that really all the time on average
on average i don't know they're special
breeds they're holding them for ransom
but even i mean in this special
technological surveillance big brother
state i don't think people
would do ransom because they would get
caught right away uh
with so much metadata i mean facebook
knows everything about you
this is why the political thing i'm i'm
questioning yeah look
look i would not entertain this normally
but the fbi is investigating a political
motive over this
and they're saying it's because she's
saying it saying it biden's inauguration
but that's kind of like
the far left was planning on protesting
hillary clinton's inauguration as well
back in 2016 and then it turned into a
trump protest
they don't like joe biden and like luke
said what ransom are you gonna be able
to get from stealing lady gaga's dogs
okay maybe they didn't know as lady
gaga's dogs
maybe they saw a guy with dogs and said
yo but i don't believe that because
these dogs are extremely valuable
yeah they likely knew where the dogs
came from they likely knew what kind of
dogs they were they had to have known it
was
lady gaga's and if that's the case
ransom would never have worked
so were they hoping to then get the
reward later from lady gaga or sell them
because they're worth a couple grand
i don't know but the fbi says political
motive and i don't i don't
look to a bunch of maga guys you know
maybe definitely not with some bleach
and some
tracking down this guy yeah and there's
more expensive things to steal right
like pursue like if you were
if you were in downtown l.a you got to
assume there's probably like
cars watches right like things that you
don't have to hold for ransom you can
just resell
it's fascinating i also do think it's
like absurd to think that some like
antifa people were like
eat the rich and then they shot this guy
and stole the dogs you know what i mean
yeah
so yeah is the fbi just reaching here
imagine being the fbi person
imagine imagine like you're an agent and
this comes across your case you're like
i'm sorry
lady gaga's dogs this is what i have to
do today yeah no no there's an fbi agent
and he's sitting in his desk and he's
like super ripped in it's like
his suit's about to rip you know his
muscles are so big and then they come
and they're like
agent johnson it's lady gaga and he goes
don't tell me her dog and he's like i'm
on it
and then it plays the theme song the dog
bounty hunter
i love it or it could be just two
dumbasses that just randomly decided to
be violent
because there's a bunch of violent
dumbasses mainly in big cities
and then the fba is like i can't fix
this i can't solve this let's just blame
politics
might as well be right yeah let me
announce that they found a
a length of rope tied off yeah in the
back of lady gaga's car and they're like
oh
yeah it's interesting a subway bag i
think was also
discovered wow that's going to be the
meme forever for all these hoaxes having
a subway sandwich
i mean it's like it has to be it also
just like okay i am i'm reminded of
what happened often because it is just
so fundamentally ridiculous and people
ran with it remember i think she deleted
the tweet but kamala harris tweeted
she's like she's like i've never known
someone as honest and as brave as jessie
smalling these
people they just crazy
it's like i imagine kamala harris is
sitting there
and you're like miss harris what's your
first name
and she goes harry
harry i can't tell the truth i have to
lie
you're like tell me just something
simple fact and she tries really hard
john yeah because it has to be a lie out
of her mouth
i wonder every single one of these
people if because uh gaga
performed at biden's thing that joe and
kamala know her
and they think that the fbi will get
more funding if they say that it might
be politically motivated then just
solved it
interesting the two people who stole the
dogs was joe and kamala
that's what i'm getting at i knew it and
it was joe with the gun he's like yeah
come on man get the dog do they get more
internal funding if it's a political
crime yeah i don't think i i think of
the the kamala harris meme where she's
like looking on the phone and looking
down and everyone was like
everyone's saying she's on the phone
with joe and what she's saying to him
and i think of her going like joe they
they found the dogs
[Laughter]
they know that it's us the gig is up no
but but you do bring up a good point
in that uh they just attach white
supremacy to everything
yep you know so if there's like a
problem so so like you know
a dog got kidnapped and the fbi can't
figure it out uh do a white supremacy
and then the left goes that explains it
and they go oh thank you there are two
fbi agents for that fake news
fake news yeah yeah that's right right
that's right
yeah yeah so we're gonna get to the
point where like you know someone's car
breaks down
and then like the he brings in the shop
and the guy looks at and goes uh
white supremacy yes and then the guy
goes oh
can you fix it well i'll do my best let
me see if i can get the adl on the phone
out here it'll just be an excuse for
like anything that goes wrong right
it's like the power will go out and then
people will be like we won't know where
the power is out in the merrell bag
ladies and gentlemen
hate crime white supremacy that's it and
they'll be like what
like that's what happened and they'll go
help us please
help us oh heavens that's big cities to
be honest yeah i was sort of saying like
i'm pretty sure this is what they're
doing and
was it la or another city there's been a
spike a purported spike i don't know if
the numbers are actually pretty solid
but
there's been a purported strike in
anti-asian american violence
and i saw someone blame they were like
well naturally it's white supremacy well
they protested for this yes new york
city they did a march against white
nationalism and the suspect who attacked
this asian guy was black
white yeah and then and in san francisco
the same thing yep it was
suspect was black and they were like but
it's white supremacy right that's what
driving
dude new york with with the attacks on
the hasidic jews all the time it's the
same thing it's like this is this is
white supremacy run rampant again
wow these people are insane that's one
of the reasons i want to be in the
cities anymore but look
i'm not we mentioned it periodically
throughout the show but like this is
just
falling apart when when you have
very clearly a black man attack an asian
man
my response is i don't care about the
race yeah it was a guy who committed a
crime
but then when all of these people are
like white supremacy was the problem and
they go march i'm like yo it was it's
it's
listen it's class it's poverty it's
education like we need to
to to help these areas not scream like
i'll tell you this i'll make i'll
simplify this okay i'll just slow down
if we see crime regardless of race and
we say
if we can alleviate poverty by targeting
class issues
and you know economic factors and
education then we can help solve that
pr problem of violence instead of doing
any of that they go it's like you know
that meanwhile throughout the meeting
and it's like the one the two two people
get a really bad one and then the third
guy gives it
and they throw out the window yeah yeah
yeah so it's like there's a guy who's
planning the table we need to do
something with all this violence and
then someone says
you know like we can blame white
nationalism we can blame trump
supporters and the third guy goes
we can just help deal with the poverty
that leads to violence
it's easier for everyone to be like how
about we just uh march against white
nationalism and
solve no problems bingo because it's
it's like the other
the problem is the alternative is you
have to slog through the hard stuff
right you have to work through the
education and like the psychology of
criminality and all the other difficult
things
family yeah and all of these other
systemic
problems that there's not a there's not
a silver bullet for and there's not a
convenient bad guy for that sounds like
hard work
exactly and you gotta target compound
interest which
undercuts the elite class of fiscal
giants they're making
100 billion dollars make you a year and
just basic 2.3 percent interest
putting in the right investments
meanwhile i love that i can't remember
which comedian said this but he was like
when you're poor
they they they charge you money right
like you're you you go to the bank
and you're you're negative so they're
like i got to charge you 35
now you're negative 50 meanwhile when
you're rich they're like ah sir you're
wealthy let me
give you some more money right that's
the way the system works is it
like i understand the idea of interest
the bank uses your money for loans or
whatever to a certain degree it's
fractional reserve it's a weird system
but like punishing the poor right that's
just
ridiculous it it was always weird to me
when i would get like an overdraft fee i
i'd like
at one point where i when i was like i
was like 18 or 19 lost a bank account
because it went negative and i couldn't
stop the negative continuing to go
negative
and i just told them i was like you
realize like i don't have money right
that's why it's negative they're like
well sir you know there is a fee
what happened was it was like uh uh if
you have less than a certain amount you
get a fee and that fee put me negative
and then i got over and then i got like
a negative yeah
gum or something like 35 bucks i had
like four bucks in the account but it
was a five dollar
checking fee because i had under a
certain amount so then it went negative
then they charged me the fee for being
negative
and i showed up and said i don't got 35
to fix this duh i was like i didn't know
you were going to charge me right then
and i'm poor
and their and their response was well if
you don't pay by next week you can incur
another free and i was like then close
the account
congratulations and yeah what are you
going to do you're going to try and get
35 bucks for me i don't have
i'd be i i'd have like negative two
dollars and then i'd buy like you get a
pack of gum and then you go get a
sandwich and then you go
buy like a 99 cent some and they charge
you 100 90
35 35 35 separate you call them and
you're like hey
i didn't know i was in the negative i'm
going to deposit some money and they're
like
i can get rid of half of your charges
you're like dude you can get rid of all
of them
yeah but if you act like a jerk they
won't help you at all there was this
crazy thing that happened in chicago
like 15 years ago with chase bank where
it was there was an error in the atms
and it wasn't subtracting money from
people's accounts
when they were withdrawing from atms and
so it led
so here's what happened though so i go
to the atm
and it was like me and my friends were
all going going to a show like a bar
venue
and i put in my card i had a couple
hundred bucks and i was like i'll take
out 20 dollars
i see the amount i take out 20 bucks i
look at the receipt and it says the
number didn't change i'm like that's got
to be wrong so i
i'll take another 20 bucks i took
another three bucks the number didn't
change and i was like what what
is this so i put my card back in and
then i was like i'm gonna take out 100
bucks 100 bucks
comes out and i got 140 bucks i look at
the receipt it didn't change and i went
this is messed up so i deposited all the
money back
no no no no no because i'm like dude
there's a baby they're gonna get you
they're gonna yeah
yeah i'm not playing games it was an
error and i thought i thought it was
gonna give me the correct readout but it
wasn't so i just
deposit put the money back in here's
what happened tons of people
started being like oh free money yeah
and then what happened the next day
the system updated everybody was
negative like 100 200 bucks
and then all the fees and everything
else and the bank was like
too bad i'm like did they do that on
purpose
because they just like imagine you do
that all the poor people think now's my
chance to get some free money because
the system is broken
no it's not it'll fix itself they
just because they they don't know
because the the amount in your account
is wrong doesn't mean they don't know
how many times you took money out right
so it updated and then said withdrawal
2020 2020 and then people were just like
i just lost all that money yeah yep dude
you said you went
with your friends to a bar venue i got
really nostalgic yeah oh yeah
really i want to go hang out at a
bahamas
i mean we have one nearby you can go
hang out yeah but not with the mask
i don't want to do this outside i just
want to go chill with like 50 people in
a bar
yeah get a ipa look around at people
so i did that last weekend this is the
first i think this is the first time
i've said this out loud at least out of
like my
apartment with my girlfriend yeah so
here's my public confession
um i went to nashville last weekend wow
i visited my brother who's down there
and he was like he he's thinking about
moving down there and so i went down and
i was like listen
i haven't seen the guy in a long time
we're super super close and i was like i
want to see him before he leaves and
you know neither of us are getting any
younger whatever and so i went down
there and i remember we went the first
night
him and someone was some of his buddies
and i remember just sitting in a bar
listening to a bar band surrounded by
people and no one was wearing masks and
i was like
this feels so wonderful
i have people like for the first time in
a year i had people physically close to
me and i was like
great step on my shoe bump into me like
give me a hug man this
is this is fine i don't mind this at
right
this is one of the reasons why i was up
in new hampshire during the summer and
spring because yeah it was normal life
up there you know
large parties large gatherings and and
you know
one of the lowest sick rates in the
nation as i say and no one told the
coronavirus in new hampshire because for
whatever reason
their rates lagged way behind everyone
else in the country
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time